so we will start this afternoon session
of these PI data Madrid and we will have
Thomas gomez Alvarez arenas that will
talk about the inverse problem so on
applause to Tomas okay thank you very
much for introduction so and a little
bit different topic now i think is good
for siesta time so and well my name is
thomas whoa Methos you said before i'm
working for the spanish national
research council here in Madrid that at
the Institute for of physical and
information technologies not far from
here so on and then and the main topic
of the talk is the the use of Python
implemented create investment techniques
to solve inverse problems so does
working
okay so a first and a brief outline of
my presentation just a definition of the
IMP what the inverse problem is in case
you are not familiar with the concept
some application of the inverse problem
in the description of what are the main
elements of these of this problem and
then brief introduction to the
optimization algorithms and mainly focus
on Grady intestine algorithms and
finally a Python implementation for
g'dalien destined algorithms for inverse
problem and a few examples so okay just
to to put a framework of the work today
i would say that at least my worker
probably the work of most of you is
focus on data and on extracting
knowledge from the data and anytime you
we try to solve this problem our main I
patha sees or our starting point is the
assumption that these data contain
information and moreover that this
information is useful so whatever that
upset can be complex can be simple can
be large can be small can be can contain
a lot of variables or maybe not a lot of
them but whatever they data set we want
to extract this information so we the
information can be married very deep
within the data set or not but what we
want to do is to track this information
and transfer this information in
knowledge so there are there are a lot
of techniques to deal with this problem
and depending on the kind of information
we want to extract depending on the
application and depending on the
complexity of a problem we can use
regression techniques machine learning
by asian-influenced statistical analysis
or it can be an inverse problem that
this list can be much much
much more longer as you can imagine but
test dimensional a few cases so today
I'm going to focus on the inverse
problem so i'll give you first the
definition is going to be a next imlay
simple case to illustrate what I'm
talking about so don't worry about this
so to define that they inverse problem
we have to first define the direct
problem because the inverse problem is
going to be the opposite one so the
other way run so direct role a pretty
simple case at one nice so imagine that
we are on the top of pisa tower and you
drop a ball do you know do you know the
model that describe how the ball is
going to fall and we know the parameters
of the model we have two parameters the
eight and the gravity and then we can
calculate the position of the mall at
any time so I have the model I have the
parameters and I can predict straight
forward Bay the results okay inverse
problem same situation I have the same
model I have the position of the ball at
several times but what I want to do now
is to assuming that the model is okay
and assuming that I have the
measurements I would like to be able to
extract the model parameters so i would
like to from this measurement to be able
to extract the original head of the
available and the value of the gravity
right and i will have a prediction and i
will try to fit the prediction into the
position and by fitting this i will
attract the parameters so it's a very
nice example and less way let's go to
something more I'd little bit more
serious right so one example with
gravitational waves probably you have
heard of that recently because when was
a lot of interesting media and the point
was that scientists of sherbet something
like this and they
presume that this is the result of two
huge masses orbiting each other around
each other and eventually collapsing and
well if eventually they came up saying
that they confirm Einstein theory
because they were able to fit the
prediction of this model into the
measurement that we have there and by
fitting this model into this prediction
into this a measurements they were able
to say how big were the masses how much
time I what is happen and what was the
amount of energy released when both
masses collide it's amazing isn't it
just from this that you can predict the
masses of two big black holes orbiting
each other and eventually colliding well
by the way this is a variant for invitin
point of view this is quite interesting
because all calculations are made using
Python and this is a very nice tutorial
you have all the data you have all the
calculation there so is if you are
interested you can have a look at
another example sonographic signal so
you have a an ultrasonic signal going
through a tissue and then I can get an
inspection of the signal something like
this and I can predict how will this
espectro look like depending on the
properties of the material but what
about if I have this measurement there
and but solving the inverse problem will
be able to just from this measurement to
be able to say how many layers of tissue
what are the thicknesses what are the
densities or elastic constant what is
the mechanical dumping and how is the
change of the mechanical damping with
frequency Wow amazing again so it's from
from just a measurement you are able to
extract a lot of information from the
media or the material or whatever you
are getting this information from
you just have to assume a model and you
have must be able to optimize and this
is the key point optimize the fitting of
the model with the measurements okay so
application three main application as a
nest and you probably already know about
them so the first one maybe the more
clear is you can obtain the model
parameters so you can obtain what are
the masses of the two of these two big
holes orbiting each other or you can
obtain the parameters of the tissue or
you can obtain whatever but you also can
confirm the model because if the model
is able to fit the measurements well
it's quite reasonable to assume that the
model is working ok is what scientists
did before we will they say that they
have confirmed and it's in theory but
this is a third point yeah I'm probably
have some data and i'm not sure what is
the best model for this data i can try
to fit different models to a data set
and eventually can came up with the
model that best fit this data set so i
can make a model selection ok well are
the main elements of the inverse problem
so the main elements is you need some
data give it a model so you you must
guess whether the physical model or that
justify this later you need an error
function is not money and normally an l2
a model normal and just to compare the
prediction with the data and then you
need an optimization algorithm and the
the work for this optimization algorithm
is going to find out the combination of
model parameters that achieve the best
agreement between the vuitton the model
according to the error function so the
output are going to be the parameters of
the model your model can be analytical
can be a computer-generated model you
can have two three four whatever many
parameters and the author of the way of
all this thing will be there to obtain
the model parameters ok maybe most of
you are more familiar with machine layer
that with inverse problem suggests
compare them because they are really
similar so assume for a moment that I
don't care very much about the model so
if i don't care very much about the
model I don't care very much about the
model parameters clear and so I don't
want to know what are the model
parameters but I want to be able to
guess what will be the model output for
any you that this is machine learning so
not fun so talk to the inverse problem a
couple of additional elements in many
cases it will be to be an iterative
solution we are going to need an initial
guess okay you have to know something if
notice but in many cases you have an
intelligence if you are sure that there
is only one solution this can be an a
completely uninformed initial guess or
whatever and the make and the model and
the algorithm eventually will find the
solution can take ages but it will
compare if you promise more difficult
believer mute initial guess and you
probably need some constraints
constraints as relationship between the
variables that you snow that can be as
we it fixed very interesting property of
inverse problem is I don't know if you
are familiar with this concept if not
you should is wall post versus ill-posed
problem and it's quite straightforward
to go in the direct prolly solution from
this point to this point but when you
arrive here and you want to go back you
may find that there's no solution back
or that there are many solutions or that
disability is not guaranteed so if you
start here you may find the solution
there but you started in a slightly
different place you may have completely
different solutions so in general people
working in this fill up to maybe 10
years ago they try to avoid always
ill-posed problems because working in a
deposed probably means that you are not
quite saying but now people starting
the work we feel post problems because
well we have some ways to deal with that
but it's going to be a little bit
difficult to strengthen our okay
optimization algorithm so the core of
the inverse problem solution is to find
is to develop an algorithm that is able
to optimize the defeating between the
model and the data and just to mention a
few of them with the unique purpose to
show you that there are many many
different options and that solving this
problem doesn't mean that you use one
particular technique that you can use
many different ones so most of them were
developed the in the 60s and some of
them more recently but there's a lot of
different algorithm so and there's a lot
of Python implemented algorithm for that
as well so you have someone inside by
your share by OPI TT or LM feet so we
are ready developed with out there and
you can use them to just to focus on one
of them in the one inside by so in this
case you have a lot of different
algorithm and you can choose the one you
want to use so the main point is to be
familiar with with the different methods
what we can do what it can do so that
you are able to know exactly that you
are using the proper algorithm for a
proper problem so I want to focus on
glade in destin algorithm because for I
think two reasons the first one is that
it's pretty easy to understand the grade
in destin technique is really easy
implement a basic code for clearly
investing is right straightforward so
it's very easy as well so it's very easy
to understand how the model how the code
work how implemented code and to have a
first feeling of what inverse problem is
and how can you solve it and so on so
okay there are some implementation of
baden testing techniques algorithm in
python as well and well
Destiny's used quite a lot in machine
learning as well so if you're familiar
with machine learning for a you are also
familiar with it with this method and
okay the key elements for gradient of
gradient deaths and techniques for
inverse problem on the Left we have the
key elements i mentioned before so the
data set model the error function and
now that the magician algorithm is going
to be a clearly invest in alverland and
in this case the key elements are the
initial guess I need an initial guess
because it is going to be an iterative
the step size so is the size of the step
I take every time I go in the in the in
the algorithm and the constraints i use
so i'll show you in detail in in what I
have now I would like to explain you the
tale interesting approach so you have
the data model and the model depends
only on the independent variable and you
have some parameters let us suppose that
you have three parameters in the model
so we can represent them in the Indian a
3d space we can use five but the
representation will be much more
difficult as you can imagine so let us
suppose that we have three and the
solution is somewhere we don't know and
we would like to reach that point you
have the data we have the model and we
have a way to compare the data with a
prediction is the error and we want to
find the point where this error is
minimum that point so the only thing
diagraph is an initial guess and I want
to be able to go from this initial guess
to a final solution so so the VI is to
to look around the point that you are at
this moment select and space around you
with a with a discretization step and
then check all points or check some of
the points around you find out the one
or not the one find out a better point
because the error is less and then move
in that direction so we check all the
points depending on the dimension the
volume to church to search is going to
be different so if we increase the
dimension
volume increase very much and so well we
want to find one point to move and we
take a step in this direction and
there's two different techniques a
systematic approach a systematic
approach means that you search all
points are you to search all the mall
and then you find out what is the best
that is what is the point where the
error is the minimum one and then you
take a step in that direction but the
other approach is quite interesting
sister gastic stochastic means as you
start searching your volume the volume
around you at random and once you get
one point that provides a better error
you go in this direction if you start
searching the volume around you at
random and the first point at the first
point you have an error that is less
than deal they want you have to before
you go in that direction and and forget
the rest so what are the main difference
well the computational cost in the first
case is going to be constant 3 to the N
and n is the dimension of the problem
but in the second case is going to be
very clearly because you can if you are
right enough to just take one step
search one point and go in that division
the incremental improve so how much they
improve you in reducing the error or a
table each step is going to be different
in the first guy is going to be optimal
you are getting the best improvement in
the error you can but in the other one
in the other case not a boy local minima
well simatic approach can be not very
good at this point and five in the same
solution do you reach the same solution
every time you run the model with the
first case yes but with second case
maybe not so you may have a cloud
different points around your dual final
guest and this is very good maybe things
not but it is because this is a way to
measure the precision of
of a of your of your method because you
have a huge dispersion of it any time
you run the model is doesn't mean that
this is not a good solution so this is
so you find a point better stochastic or
systemic and once you get the point you
take a step in that direction and you
start game and this will be the summary
of the whole thing so you initially
guessed you bought the volume around you
you find a point and you go in that
direction and if the error is good
enough you can say the broad myself it's
not if it is not you start again and so
on so a python implementation so if they
decode slides will the codes a Python
code and this also up by some notebook
that i will upload in the in the
conference well there just 22 main
function one is say one is the one day
or the other botanist they want to check
the the error around your point and the
other one is the one that is calling
this every time you take a step in this
process so they're quite simple
functions and we also implement this
function here is quite interesting
because this function here allows us to
do the palapa model that is able to run
for whatever number of parameters and
you don't have to determine the number
of parameters beforehand so the model
can run for 24 3 4 10 and you don't have
to say how many beforehand and and then
we define a class object for a for a
fitting object so that we can do
different things with that so some
examples because with sample see I think
the situation can be more clear very
very simple samples play as simple as
the piece of that word problem the
beginning okay linear regression so have
this problem as the data and I have the
model
and I want to extract a model parameter
so slope and intercept so this should
work right it does and you can run the
stochastic or the systematic reinvesting
approach and what we have here is a plot
in the in the space of the parameter so
we want to know this is the near initial
guess and this is a target value and if
you store at each step what are changing
the parameters you can see that you are
going for the initial point and you
nicely arrived are the target value and
this is the stochastic and this is the
de creating lesson and quite interesting
is that the puff alone the stochastic
approach is longer clearing but it is
faster as well because you don't have to
pick because you don't have to search
the whole volume every time you want to
take a step it can be much faster and
this is especially important in large
dimension problems in a large summation
problem searching the whole ball unit on
a single point can take ages so you can
run the stochastic case two times and
you are going to have a different path
clearly you arrive at the same point
almost at the same point ok this is the
red one is our target value the yellow
one is the solution of the problem using
the side billion regress and we run the
model the stochastic lady intestine
model 200 times and I obtain these two
different sets of the data so something
like that we have multiple solutions
they're pretty close so it really
doesn't matter what but we can be a word
that okay that there can be a problem
and we are plotting from these two
hundred times where protein all solution
who server is less than a minimal
solution plus a five percent okay we can
reduce this limit we can ah we get rid
of that and the systematic dating
think was on the run on the wrong place
you can run the Python code it all times
you warm because the model is going to
be always the same but every time you
run the model the noise is different and
every time you run them all that you are
going to have a something different
because it's the rice is different
there's also going to be different and
this is another case for example okay
something similar and this is another
one in disguise the site the link
regress prediction is the worst one and
in this case if you reduce the if you
increase the position you wanted a in
the in the solution to get nothing so
you keep these two but they're really
close so you can be a word that you have
to solution but they are very close
would you really don't care very much
well another case very simple it would
be something like this so kind of you
can do the same now the path to the
solution is going to be a
three-dimensional one and as before
stochastic case is longer but faster
different run different times you have
different paths and while the new have
you can run these different times and
you have a cloud of pots and there's a
function to plot this and ok ok
something more complex let's go see a
Cygnus in the time domain and we are
going to jump this one because nothing
ok this is what we call a linear chair I
don't know if you are familiar with a
chirp chirp is for example squad using
electronics in ultrasonics a chirp is
for example the sound that the pad
produce it to localize the brain then
normally a must approve approve of so
this is a signal whose frequency change
with time so this is the law that
predict this kind of signal is going to
be our model and we have three
parameters and we want to do the same so
it's something will be something similar
to what we have before and we can run
the model and half a good fitting this
could be a gain linear chip something
similar as the one before but the
amplitude is increasing as the time goes
by and with an initial guess close to
the final solution and this what you
have well you can compare the feeding of
the top of the two and they and the path
in the in the space of a the parameters
of space and you can see that in the
first k there are two clear legs so we
start going down and then we won't need
depth but in the second case we are
missing one part and this is because
because of the attenuation at the
beginning because at the beginning the
signal is so low we lose some precision
there and we are not able to fit this
parameter so in this case it will be
important to be to be aware that it's
going to be able to fit this parameter
so better not put in this parameters on
the model because it's going to be
completely misleading and this is
something related to model selection so
doing this we learn that the model in
this case is too difficult to too
complex so it is really a kind of an
ill-posed problem because in this case
will we will get no information about
the parameter on this x-axis here
because with London another problem with
signals in the time domain that changed
this way isn't solution is that the
initial guess must be very close to the
final solution if not we can be you can
be trapped in a local minimum is that it
is one you have a very good fitting at
the beginning a pretty good fitted at
the end but only the middle and because
of that this is a minimal and you are
not able to get rid of that so you are
trapped there so you can increase the
step size and you can solve the first
problem but not the second and a pretty
good idea in this case is to work in the
in the frequency domain so we stopped
working the time domain and we transform
the data from the time domain to the
frequency domain and we operating in the
frequency domain
for those of you familiar with that this
is a fast fourier transform fft so they
di so transform things in time so this
is the signal from them this is the what
is called the mass chirp chirp is
because it's a it's a way similar to the
one we have seen before a master because
this is the wave produced by these two
big holes colliding and so on and in
this case they the law of the mass chirp
is bottom right and the measurement were
on top and the VI was to try to fit the
model to this data and the only thing
outsourcing the paper and this paper
said about this problem is it's these
two lines in a figure caption and this
is something very common in physics
engineering biology and so on and so on
all people trying to fit a model to some
beta to extract some parameters the
normally said we often the fitting and
we have flying the bed we are from the
best fitting and is this and they
normally do not say the details and many
many many cases they only have an
initial guess didn't have the effort
didn't put the effort to title to solve
the Corporal so in this case the
original measurement was once the one
top left and for me pry for you as well
this is pure noise this is no more than
9 but they put the translated the
frequency domain the filter the signal
they catered one and they eventually
okay it eventually get that one so
another case this is a this is an
ultrasonic signal that goes through a
tissue geography may be seen in this
kind of application and this is the
signal we have we know this will be the
sinner will present problems in the
frequency domain in the time domain so
go to the frequency domain and this is
what the signal looks like in the
frequency domain so you have a a pattern
of resonances and you can try to fit
well the good point in this case is we
have five parameters quite a lot
and / interesting solution is if in many
cases to solve a problem means not only
that you know about our algorithms but
that you also know about the specific
properties of the problem you want to
solve and if you don't know very much
about the problem then you will spend
most of the time in the algorithm
learning about the poor so in this case
what happens is that they the last
parameter is the one that their minds
disagrees and this is the only
parameters the only one parameter doing
that so the idea is to forget this one
fit the first part of the curve and now
i have a four parameters problem but CCO
to solve and then use this information
to go back to the previous one and this
will be the fitting within the key in
the first case and then you have the the
other one so this will be the similar
images as before in this case you have
to select how many what are the
parameters you want to represent because
you only can represent three and you
have five ok and ok a very interesting
way to deal with a large dimension
problem is this couple capability to to
split the problem into two so if I know
that some of the parameters affect some
pot some part of the autumn a problem
I'm some other effect other part then
what I can do it I can separate I will
reduce the dimension of the problem and
they can start fitting one part of the
problem then performing at least stop go
back to the others and so and so on
until we arrive to the to the final
solution and very briefly this is what
we have done here in this case you have
ten parameters and this is a very
complex problem but which you can start
solving the first part and then you
obtain the first five parameters you can
use these parameters to have a rather
good initial guess for the rest of the
problem put these on the problem and try
to solve it
the whole problem so eventually we
managed but the the main message here is
that no matter the company's the problem
is that is the second there are
techniques that enable you to strike
parameters from simple measurement and
this can give you information about the
million euro you were investigating or
they prolong the war time dealing with
that it can be completely impossible to
imagine in beforehand so i can write to
the Q&A quick park it and sell it is a
kind ofit yogi the direct approach to
the q and I question will be that you
asked and I respond the inverse problem
is that I respond and you have to guess
requested what the question was and this
is clear that it can be an ill-posed
problem because if my answer is no you
cannot guess the question but if my
answer is yes we have tried but you're
sort of much closer to that okay so
thank you thanks
so we have arrived in five minutes for
questions questions this is interesting
talk it was also to continue in the
light-hearted tone that at last you see
that this stochastic the expiratory ways
need some hand tuning on the number of
variables that have to be sorted one
could would even tell that you are
conjugating by yet by hand the
stochastic gradient did you were you
have to choose by do you have do some
previous knowledge of which variables or
did you exhaust the audio was caused by
chance okay I'd like to extend a little
the question how much what you do by
kind of optimizing that is intuition and
yeah I think it will it could be truly
interesting to explore this idea when
you have no information about the data
so this will be really very interesting
so because you know that this can work
when you have some knowledge about the
problem and you can you can do some kind
of interaction with that but probably
can be very interesting to try to do
this when you know nothing so try to
guess different different ways to
aggregate your parameters and try to run
the algorithm and to see what its kind
can be very interesting right any other
question so like stang to us I'm sorry
one more
thank you for a presentation one
question when you use the stochastic
criteria for the chains how do you
evaluate the convergence to the point
well m you have two different
possibilities right if you but well you
can run the model with a problem that
you already know so you can check if you
what you get is what you're expecting to
get when you are using a a problem that
you don't really know the solution
usually the noise should come back and
is okay or not well good way is to look
at there if you are having different if
you have multiple solution or not this
can be a good approach to to know how
how good is the algorithm performing so
if you have different solution and you
have no way to use constraints to
eliminate some of this solution then you
may have a problem but we may have time
for another question now let's thank the
speaker again